today is going to be the best day ever I
love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love Doug hey
shut the [__] up [__] piece of [__]
that's Doug the best owner in the world
we're playing this game called Fetch and
[__] [__] he drops me off really far
away and drives home without me when I
bring the ball back he says [__] that's
how I know I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so but thank you
thank you for me kid he left your ass oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
duck doesn't love me poor little guy I
should probably talk to him I am a
therapy dog Rich you can learn how
beautiful he can be when you're off the
leash this beer is making me dizzy he's
about to get real Dizzy up in this [__]
I'm having a great time this
[__] right here make me a little
[__] ass friend with the [__]
home perm and [__] what did you just say
I really hate for this to get violent
you were straight you can do anything
you want I'm going back to Doug's what
the [__] man he needs to pay for what he
did with the only thing he truly loves
I'm gonna bite his dick
oh wait did he just say yeah I'm still a
little drunk but I said I'm gonna bite
his dick off oh we gon [__] [__] up
big day today you ever humped anything
before I wouldn't say I've humped per se
there you go red I'm doing good tell him
you're his daddy hey gnome I'm your
father it's good to finally meet you
right even under these strange
circumstances
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now so how exactly could this get worse
oh my God
oh
[__] guys we've got a dick to Ripper
what are those what kind of looks like
food oh [__] uh give me a second you
look different [__] you look different
too how so is it my human hands